man brauche ich acht spielen systec doch
einfach ein cooler macht echt so wenig
nur der shop kann
hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück in
schutz ich werde das jetzt hier sollte
daran ist es traditionell setzen ich das
vergessen zu ziehen ist ein ganzes
abgebaut das boston jetzt fehlen erklär
mir mal ich habe eine neue idee ich will
mich so eine art altes haus bot
musikalisches feld januar stehen lassen
das passt auch mehr so allgemeine diese
idylle hier wollen sondern was mal
beginnen wir mal direkt am anfang der
folge mit dem team gleich da könnt ihr
uns auch in die kommentare ein tolles
thema immer direkt am anfang sagen was
ist bloss oder dass wir das aber erst im
laufe der folge sein
eigentlich ja danke thema von steffen
dvl minecraft hat uns geschrieben
youtube konkurrenz unter den channel
würde mich interessieren was zwiebel
dass du zu überdenken und zu viel
minecraft auf youtube fragezeichen
also man das machen denkt vor allem weil
er gern verbreitet ist jeder scannt ist
kosten nicht wir sind schwer zu erlernen
das kann jeder irgendwie spielen egal ob
jetzt ein shooter fan ist oder beim
adventure fans darum spielen zeit viele
muss man kreativ sein kann viele
verschiedene sachen machen
darum geht es auch gar nicht gefragt ob
er bis zu vier minecraft auf youtube
nicht warum es so viele minecraft auf
youtube gibt ja das kann man trotzdem
kurz anschneiden deswegen gibt es halt
so viel du brauchst nicht mal ein brot
mit anschauen weil dann jeder kann jeder
schauen was er möchte und man kann die
sonst zu viele katzen videos auf youtube
bietet ist darum wir sind ja nicht im
fernsehen
wir bezahlen keine gez dafür jeder kann
hochland wasser möchte und eine gute
belohnung gez war das letzte thema nicht
in dieser folge dass das wohl egal
der daumen kann man muss sich einfach
nicht mein kraft anschauen
darum kann will ich nicht sein das ist
es zu viel gibt wenn die leute das gerne
gucken und das viele leute gibt die es
anbieten
dann ist das die logische konsequenz
einer vorhergehenden gesetz von angebot
so ich sage es mal so ich mache das
thema von steffen sowieja das gedacht
und zwar finde ich eigentlich ist nicht
schlimm bzw finde ich sogar gar nicht
dass es jetzt so immens viel minecraft
auf youtube gibt natürlich die meisten
gaming videos sind glaube ich sogar in
neuen jahres kann es offen zu sagen aber
ich meine es ist ein spiel was sehr bei
jedem anders jetzt sage ich mal zum
beispiel es gibt leute die können
einfach richtig geil bauen es gibt leute
die stellen mods texture pack 2 es gibt
leute die machen adventure maps es gibt
leute die drehen filme in minecraft es
ist quasi schon wie sonnen multi
funktionen
das programm womit man halt sehr sehr
viele verschiedene dinge machen kann und
gerade das macht es ja so interessant
deswegen macht es auch so viele und ich
finde das eigentlich sehr sehr geil dass
das so viele leute machen und finde
jetzt eigentlich gar nicht dass es so
negativ gesehen ist der doch auch gesagt
es gibt etwa ist in die playlist es gibt
so viele fragen wie jeder hat jetzt
jeder kommt es mittlerweile einfach
geschaut ich zuerst doch alles besteht
das geht
na ja die wählen ja auch immer geschaut
von minecraft also ich denke meine
krankheit 900 folgen und trotzdem ist es
noch interessant also nicht dabei aber
ich denke mal dass er das also wenn ich
da ab und zu mal reinschaut dann hat es
macht immer noch gut das ist immer noch
interessanter
also es muss nicht nur weil viele macht
das ding ist ja dass viele schlecht
machen viele fangen jetzt an machen
minecraft letzter über das man ja alles
ist ja auch einfach kann ich auch aber
dann ist es halt auch schlecht und dann
chance hat auch niemand aber es werden
uns nicht auch mut in minecraft displays
geben kann nachrichten habe ich auch
dauernd bekommen dauer ich habe heute
noch eine gesehen als ich gucke da echt
eigentlich immer recht häufig rein aber
ich antworte halten bzw nur auf
konstruktiv nur auf sinnvolle fragen die
nicht schon tausendmal beantwortet
wurden und da was will ich
ich wollte runter und gucken ob du was
für bücherregale hast ja und warum
fragst du da nicht einfach weil ich
wollte fragen aber durch wollte ich erst
ausreden lassen
ich habe noch bücherregal von aus der
pyramide gefunden geklaut meinten du
sollst echte angewöhnen erste frau heim
war es sei jetzt sache kommen wir sicher
war noch eigentlich bücherregal
die uns fragen
es ist auch unsere verhält damit zu tun
weil so werkzeugen so was aber könnte
ich sein haus demontieren und bei dir
viel hoffnung vielleicht wird ist ein
haus einfach verschieben
was sollten wir machen
ich muss manchmal kann es sein lassen
manche kartoffeln total langsam wachsen
ich werde meine in kraft
macht euch kein unterschied stock stein
ich habe scheint
ich muss ja alles erstmal abholzen
weil kartoffeln sind mit abstand das
effektivste nahrungsmitteln also
isingens bis nicht all zu bringen
kraft oder den holzblock den man für 1
tag braucht den nur noch verschmerzen
oder die eine kohle schauen die insel
trauriger 14 stück der nachtisch sagen
man brauche nicht viel es ist doch
einfach so wenig nur der shop kann
aber wie lange hast du einen stack
kartoffeln ewig
es gibt keine zeit 15 tage
ja und mehr und noch 19 6 und das gab
erfahrung ich habe 31
in den büchern von tablets aufbauen
da war nur drei stück oder woher hast du
direkt in der kiste und drei bücher
regale und zwei stapel papier
wir hatten aber vor ort alles folgende
regeln das finde ich januar soll der
mann aber das blog abbaut und
zwischendrin wechselt man den gegenstand
womit man das abort damals war das mal
scheißegal nun wird das gestoppt dann
das wusste ich gar nicht runter von
meiner kiste
entschuldigung ich nehme an der seite
heraus wie bist du darauf gekommen
was einigen update seitdem die sich zu
öffnen
das war glaube ich und mein abo ahnung
von neun kräften aber du weißt dass es
da so mit den bäumen und seine sachen
wegfällt verstehen was das 30 lausanne
hat gesagt dass man die sachen dass man
den gegenstand jetzt nicht mehr wechseln
kann der blogger putz ja das weiß ich
und das mit den kirchen im osten sind es
im buch stellt
17 book chefs habe ich und papier an
unmengen aber ich muss er bücher machen
wie man bücher mit leder nicht nur
rädern ich hab drei macke wir müssen mal
unbedingt seine weg beleuchtung machen
bei dem die web bildet sich wir haben
immer mehr gebäude hier um einen
hinzubekommen was gibt tageslicht lachen
was für tageslicht im wasser im
smartphone-sektor peter gemacht ihr mann
bernd dass die wenn dunkle geht eine tür
durch oder so dann sind schalter
gedrückt das irgendwie so im ganzen dorf
redstone lampen angehen und alles so
bling bling macht und das geht hat mit
dem red dot ganz einfach so ab mixed up
date mit einem daylight things can
reimer darf wieder quarz blade switch
nicht das ist was anderes
das werden blogs oder so ich bin nicht
antritt muss mich bilden bis 15 update
selbst selbstsicheren scheiße ich bin zu
blöd mir irgendwie mein haus kaka
aufgeteilt ich weiß nicht was ich wohin
packen
sollte sie einfach so eine offene
bibliothek einfach mal machen
das ist von einer von euch rohholz von
weblinks 1991 alles mal habe ich auch
selber nicht ich glaube ich eine grippe
habe das gar nicht beantworte mit
youtube kanäle aber von der konkurrenz
unter youtube kann ihn herrlich doch die
frage auf minecraft gezogen das war der
zweite teil der fragen die zweite frage
ist zwar youtube konkurrenz unter den
channel fragezeichen oder zuviel
minecraft auf youtube schon ziemlich
viel konkurrenz würde ich sagen also
jetzt nicht in jedem bereich aber
speziell bei minecraft enkel wie meinst
du das nein wer sich da alles an greift
gegenseitig und wasser einfach so los
ist auch so in bezug auf so einen
gewissen großen youtuber gerne groß ist
wollen wir jetzt noch mal ganz
kurzzeitig zum schau die das immer in
die kommentare schreiben wird nicht in
die tüte verstaut
ich habe jetzt konkurrenz und kanälen er
so verstanden dass man sich jetzt
irgendwie gegenseitig kanäle irgendwie
kongress haben im sinne von die hassen
sich alle gegenseitig und oder man
schnappt sich gegenseitig zuschauer oder
sowas weg aber an sich hatte hat man ja
auch ein bisschen vielleicht
unterschiedliche stile unter einem
schaut halt lieber den ruhigeren zum
beispiel halt bronk etwas ruhiger
vielleicht sind und über irgendwelche
sachen dann halt reden und die anderen
schon eher fleck tvp sachen zb bei den
europa- oder irgendwelchen anderen und
das weißt du ganz und anja mehr zeit
schon viele kanäle und weniger zeit
schauen weniger aber und jeder macht
halt so ein bisschen halt produziert
seine sachen und dann kommt halt an weil
manche leute nun bei die andere mit mehr
an weniger auch sagen gerade es gibt
aber ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass ich
so denken wie scheiße entwendet das
macht dann muss ich das auch machen oder
so also wenn ich mich so mit anderen
kanälen irgendwie vergleichen würde dann
würde ich sonst sagen dass ich
vielleicht darauf achte dass ich eben
nicht genau das mache was die schule
machen oder wenn ich ein neues projekt
mache dann schaue ich erstmal da macht
das niemand anderes oder so dass es dann
das gleiche machen was ich noch sagen
würde ist man findet sage ich mal in
jeder in jedem man findet immer das was
man sucht sage ich mal
also jeder es bestehen immer so
unterschiede in den in den spielen der
verschiedenen lecks player bzw
minecraft auf youtube und wenn man jetzt
zum beispiel der typ ist der ja wie den
hals meinte bvb sachen wie gehen wir
dann geht mein oder wenn man hier immer
neuen gast sehen will dann guckt man
sich die toilette an wenn man
durchgehend des play sehen will wo man
täglich folgen bekommt und immer super
kommentierte anzukommen und man man hat
halt diese diese unterschiede sagt das
ist eigentlich ganz gut
ich finds
das ist diese gesunden unterschiede gibt
ich bin ja in einer in einer
konfettiwolke immer relativ viel
diskutiert wird
oder was ist ergebnis nach vorne erich
in der gamestar konnten
ich weiß ich warum ich da noch nicht
rausgeworfen wurde aber auch das kann
man ja ganz gut auch mal klar stellen
ich bin einfach mit mit gamestar nicht
hundertprozentig zufrieden gewesen für
mich das kann für andere super alles
klappen aber bei mir war es einfach
nicht ganz so und danach mit anderen
netzwerken gesehen und dann vieles
verglichen und für mich familie kraft
einfach am interessantesten für dich
richtig ja genau also media kraft es
auch das netzwerk was in youtube
deutschland immer so groß diskutiert
wird und ganz viele ganz ganz schlimm
finden aber wie kann ich jetzt noch
sagen also da sind mehr gerüchte
irgendwo sonst auch die media kraft das
den als abgenommen und so große youtube
schon irgendwie ja aber ihr wieder weiß
wenn ich meine die haben auch eine
million abonnenten als erster richtiger
deutscher youtube kanal ist jetzt
mittlerweile ihr und dass da irgendwie
nur media kraft also als logisch ist
dass man bei so einem großen plan album
so viele views generiert werden wo so
viel geld deswegen generiert wird dass
man da halt sich auch professionalisiert
und deswegen da natürlich auch sich
leute ran holt und das nicht nur zu
dritt alleine machen sondern denen da
auch die sich einfach leute engagieren
und das ist nicht das irgendwie da
nichts mehr machen oder nicht leitend im
kreativen prozess werden aber auch nicht
alles bestimmen weil jeder zwölfte die
drei die das machen
eine idee haben kann es auch sein dass
media kraft in sachen
würde ich nicht machen also das kann
schon sein hier haben wir haben einen
großen einfluss darauf haben was ich
hier an ich finde dass freiheit in der
in der nächsten folge weil alter was ist
das eigentlich für ein komisches ach die
haben uns am anfang eingebaute navi
komische hürde war goldrichtig
dabei sind haben jetzt mal ein bisschen
die frage beantwortet von die vier in
minecraft der die in den kommentaren auf
facebook gepostet hatte und in der
nächsten folge jetzt dann noch speziell
um youtube netzwerke wahrscheinlich
interessiert es ja relativ viele von
euch haben das gefühl kriegen könnten
wir ein bisschen medien kraft wird die
stimme gleichen netzwerk
ich bin gar kein netzwerk unter bin sehr
zufrieden denn ohne zweck und wir sehen
uns in der nächsten folge finanz